what's going on guys this is Rob and
we're in it now son we are in the thick
of it now man let me show you something
oh my god dude the ending of this story
is nuts oh you guys are gonna hate me
a story so what this does is this picks
up again with the cree Armada attacking
earth now for those of you guys catching
up with us make sure you check the
playlist down in the description it'll
get you caught up on everything that
we've done so far but the long and short
of this is that the cree created the
Inhumans and then the cree wanted to
wipe out the Inhumans because there was
a prophecy that the Inhumans would
destroy the cree so what the Supreme
intelligence having returned it sets its
sights on Earth because it's believed
that's where the last inhuman group
resides basically right and that and we
know that's true like you have Black
Bolt of the Inhumans you have all these
guys who are here right so the idea of
the cree is launching a full-scale
attack against Earth and when I say a
full scale I mean the entire Cree Armada
is here now the reason for that is
because remember in Marvel Comics some
of the most powerful beings and in fact
the most powerful beings in the universe
reside on earth right you have like
Franklin Richards you have all these
guys right I mean Earth is in is just
it's crazy how op Earth is so the cree
need the Armada now that's the crazy
thing here is because you do have
Susan's storm with her force fields
holding things off as best they can but
the Baxter building is only one part of
the equation the invasion of the cree
Armada is against everybody in New York
the entire city and so as a result it's
a full contingent of the Avengers the
X-Men the Fantastic Four everybody's
there of course Johnny Storm's not there
because again Johnny Storm is basically
dead and so what you get is you have
this full-on attempt by all these
different superheroes uniting under the
banner of saving the city of New York
from everyone now they do what they can
where they can but again there's also
unforeseen consequences for example
Doctor Strange is able to steer away a
cruise ship by basically taking it down
but as opposed to it flying towards the
water it crashes into a building so
again collateral damage yeah it sucks
but it's just one of those things that
happens and so at that point we
transitioned to the other side of zero
where you have the Angie priest now
remember the other side of zero is a
night Club in the city of New York
that's masquerading as a nightclub and
in reality it houses basically the
forces of annihilus members of the
annihilation wave residing on Earth
trying to find a way to open the portal
to the negative zone so the annihilation
wave and annihilus can re-enter into the
main Marvel Universe and destroy
everything right remember annihilus is a
nihilist himself right life is
meaningless he wants to basically just
destroy and end all things in existence
but with this major attack happening the
anti-priest realizes this was unexpected
and in order for them to be able to
secure their goal they have to open a
portal to the negative zone now there is
no waiting and so when contacting a
nihilus anilas responds yes open the
portal to the negative Zone get it open
as fast as you can so while all this is
happening basically the forces from the
other side of zero invade the Baxter
building now the crazy thing about this
is that you do have the Future
Foundation there meaning Franklin
Valeria those guys they are present
there but before we get to them we
switch back over to the cree Armada and
and we have the Inhumans who have shown
up to basically the cree Armada itself
now that's when the Supreme intelligence
realizes the anomaly quote unquote
blackfold the inhuman who is prophesized
to destroy the entirety of the cree
Armada that he's here and so what they
do is they break off a segment of their
forces from the attack to launch an
attack against the Inhumans now again
while that's happening what you had was
this idea of the Avengers to basically
find a way to safeguard the city of New
York now this is going to be a
Monumental moment here I want you to
keep this moment in the back of your
head because what they do is they push
Susan Storm's force fields to a greater
level than she's ever experienced before
what they do is they basically use her
abilities to create force fields and
they tap it into the power of Tony Stark
and so literally when she creates a
force field Tony Stark's Powers amplify
it but it requires her to push her
powers to the limit in order to ensure
the force fuel can stay intact and so
once the perimeter is pushed further out
the force fields erected and the the
entirety of New York is under the
protection of the force field itself
meaning the only forces that are here
are the forces that were basically
ground troops now there is a bit of a
battle there is somewhat of a skirmish
that takes place it's not overly
important of course she-hulk's taken out
which is no surprise uh red Hulk's taken
out which is a surprise right and this
is all done by the cree centuries
remember the centuries are kind of the
the foot soldiers that get sent in
before the cree soldiers arrive and the
centuries are just giant robots is
really all they are but because they're
so capable and because they're so easily
built it would make a lot more sense to
send them in as opposed to Cree soldiers
which would basically diminish the the
entire population of the cree Empire and
so as a result of this what we end up
doing is jumping to the Baxter building
itself when the force is from the other
side of zero invade the Baxter building
now when they get here of course the
kids aren't necessarily prepared for it
but again because you're dealing with
forces of annihilus not all these kids
are Godly in terms of powerful now
Franklin Richards is here and Franklin
Richards could use his powers to keep
every like to end everything like that
in the blink of an eye and a lot of you
guys are probably going to be asking
yourself why isn't Franklin Richards
just using his crazy powers to end all
this there's a reason for that there's a
reason why Franklin Richards is not
using his powers and we'll find out what
that reason is later on right probably
next week when we get the greatest
moment ever in the history of Marvel
Comics oh my God it is so ridiculous
dude I'm so man I'm so excited man I'm
so excited for that this dude is gonna
be oh my God it's gonna be so
ridiculously amazing but but again you
know with these guys trying to keep
their forces at Bay as best they can or
at least keep the forces of the cree at
Bay the Future Foundation these kids led
by Valeria Richards basically hit an
Evac button right it's a button that
basically teleports the Future
Foundation to a different location it
was a safety measure that was built by
both the Future Foundation and Reed
Richards in case anything popped off and
so what ended up happening is Spider-Man
literally tells Reed you stay here you
focus on this Susan needs you here I
will go deal with the Baxter building
and so when Spider-Man gets there of
course he finds the forces of annihilus
from the other side of zero who were
trying to open the portal to the
negative zone now here's the thing this
is man this is this is one of the cool
moments it's not the coolest moment but
it's a really good moment right it's a
really good moment so Spider-Man shows
up here and this is the thing Spider-Man
is able to take these guys on and for
the most part over power one of the
things that I do want to specify about
what you're seeing here and you guys can
tell we're only seven minutes in right
so like we got a lot more going on in
this video than what I've covered so far
man [ __ ] is about to pop off dude it's
about to go absolutely nuts so here's
the thing right so Spider-Man is able to
face these guys but this is one of the
only times that you're ever going to see
Earth superheroes face off against the
annihilation wave remember when the
original Annihilation event happened it
opened up basically out in space it took
place out there beyond Earth while the
annihilation event was happening Civil
War was happening on Earth so you really
didn't have any of Earth's superheroes
focus on that event in fact Richard
Ryder showed up to Earth Nova showed up
to Earth and was like Hey guys there's a
much bigger thing going on here the
universe is at stake and the superheroes
are like blarg Civil War you have to
register so he's like nah I'm good peace
that dude peace down went right back to
the battle again he's like our
superheroes are useless all ain't
nothing we can do we just got to worry
about this on our own now the problem
with this is that while Peter is facing
off against the forces of of the other
side of zero that they managed to attach
a disc to the portal for the Negative
Zone and that's counting down and while
Peter's trying to trying to stop him the
number keeps counting down right it
keeps counting and then eventually
Peter's not able to stop the door from
opening so the Negative Zone portal
opens up and what it does Johnny Storm
is waiting for Peter Parker that's right
ladies and gentlemen Johnny Storm is
alive and we will find out exactly how
it was he survived here don't worry I'm
not going to leave y'all hanging on that
well I kind of am because we're not
going to cover it in this video but the
surprises keep coming ladies and
gentlemen because while you have Susan's
storm and you've got Iron Man Who were
over there with the force field
technology and everything going on the
cree soldiers are at least a handful of
Cree soldiers their special ops team
basically teleport to Earth they
detonate Obama and they sabotage it so
ultimately the force field comes
crashing down now at that point the
crease centuries over they overpower Ben
Grimm who's like the last guy left to
stand against them right so there's not
a whole lot they can do so you got
Johnny Storm he's talking to Spider-Man
Peter Parker's like dude we're in a
pinch man like we're literally losing
the cree Armada not only are they going
to destroy the city of New York they're
gonna eradicate the entirety of Earth
like everything's gone there's nothing
we can do to win here man like time's up
and so the response of of Johnny is okay
I've got a solution let me take care of
something first and to show the world
that he's alive he flies up into the sky
and creates the burning Fort it's his
Insignia right it's like Johnny Storm's
thing it's like his thing right they
always do it right so it's his way of
showing like I'm very much alive and so
what ends up happening is in that
realization it kind of gives Ben Grimm a
sort of renewed Vigor right so he's back
into the front again but at the end of
the day it doesn't really make any
difference everybody is falling right
the forces are falling against the power
of the cree Armada it's just way too
capable and it's just way too strong and
so in the end like while the Fantastic
Four do have a nihilus under their
control Johnny Storm says okay here's
the thing yes the cree Armada is beyond
our ability to defeat but I've got an
Ace in the Hole I've got the cosmic
control rod and always remember unless
we forget he who controls the cosmic
control rod controls the annihilation
wave I control the annihilation wave
unleash hell right like they just come
pouring out of the portal like Mad Men
he literally starts opening portals all
around New York right those portals come
flooding out the annihilation wave just
unleashes onto the entire Cree Armada
here's the crazy thing about that where
Johnny is able to lead the the
annihilation wave against the cree
Armada at the end of the day lest we
forget Annihilation happened and because
Annihilation happened the cree Empire
retrofit their technology or their ships
to make sure that if the annihilation
wave ever first they would be prepared
for it so Johnny Storm despite the fact
that he's able to offer help he's
fighting a losing War there's nothing he
can do to win here right I mean they can
hold off as best they can and they are
doing decent enough but in the midst of
all this you do have Susan who looks at
Reed and says Reed we do have an ace in
the hole right we've gotta we've got
we've got a way that we can win this but
Reed is hesitant to do it right he's
like I don't know if I'm willing to do
this it's something that I'm not
entirely sure of because I don't know
what would happen if we did it could
lead to the ruin of all or it could lead
to the day being saved and so while
that's going on you basically have
forces from the cree Empire who managed
to invade the warship or the the the
capital ship of Johnny Storm Now The
Avengers The Fantastic Four they step in
and do what they can where they can but
at the end of the day they're not going
to win nothing's going to happen because
those Cree soldiers invade they take out
Reed they basically temporarily
incapacitate Susan storm and then they
go to like destroy the entirety of the
vessel now the thing about this is that
you do have have Spider-Man you got
Johnny Storm you got those guys who
tried to destroy this Crete Armada to
the best of their abilities but here's
the thing fighting off against these
Cree forces is no easy thing one the
cree are exceedingly strong and
Incredibly durable right they are more
than enough for any regular superhero
think of it think of them as like
Captain America Amplified several times
over in terms of strength speed agility
and that's just a regular Cree add into
that the various enhancement that
they've had through their physiology as
well as the advanced technology their
arms and Armament these guys are hard to
defeat the worst part about all this for
the different superheroes on Johnny
Storm's battleship is that you're now
talking about the crease Special Forces
not only is it all the stuff that I just
mentioned these guys are trained to kill
like they are wildly capable and so
these guys overpower Ben Grim they
overpower Peter Parker and they actually
get to Susan storm now the funny thing
about this is Susan storm makes this
comment she's like look I'm sorry boys
but I'm in a bit of a rush right now I
assume that you're going to politely
move out of the way and just let me get
on with it right and like they're
literally just got guns trained on her
she's like all right then right she
literally encases herself in a force
field in cases their heads in force
fields destroys all of them and sends
them flying out there right as soon as a
storm man will be tied the poor soul
that decides to mess with this chick
that's why I'm telling y'all man
depending on how the Marvel Cinematic
Universe handles Susan's storm that
chick's a horse you ain't seen nothing
right Carol Danvers she's decent enough
like she's okay she can do some stuff
and she's kind of cool I guess but like
Susan storm she's on a whole nother
level right like she's it's man I'm
excited to see what she's able to do but
in the midst of all that Johnny Storm's
like you know what I've had enough like
enough of this right dude uses this
power shuts down the entirety of the
crew forces right just annihilates all
the cree soldiers on his warship and
it's just like okay let's get back to it
again now here's the thing you have the
Supreme intelligence and asked one of
his soldiers for a report right and this
guy says as expected the wave has
cracked before our Armada meaning our
ability to retrofit our ships in
preparation for another potential
Annihilation wave attack which we didn't
know this was going to happen but it's
fortuitous that it did our ability to
retrofit our ships for that it's paid
off right the annihilation wave is not
able to hold against our ships more so
than that the anomaly City shows power
fluctuations and a flat Vector its path
will bring it into our shadows in effect
the attilan city is basically going to
explode at some point in time it can't
maintain its shifts and it doesn't have
any real propulsion and it's on our way
to us we will ensnare it quite readily
and so at that moment Susan storm and
Reed Richards do the only thing they can
do Sanson man I told you all last video
is going to be important right like
literally Reed says this is it we're in
the right place and see the storm says
I'll seal the room now reach says before
I do this maybe I'm not thinking of
everything maybe there's another
solution are we sure and the response of
Susan is on Earth death metal is falling
from the sky much more will follow I'm
sure triggering the effects of a nuclear
winter he said a season of dying
remember and so Reid's like okay then I
guess we do it right this guy activates
the ark that was given to him right and
then just that's it every head turns
this just like Wormhole appears out of
nowhere right like just behind everybody
this Wormhole literally opens up and out
of this Wormhole comes none other than
Galactus that's right ladies and
gentlemen rid Richard's Summit Galactus
to the battle and this guy man let me
tell you something this dude's about to
unleash hell man I'm sorry I'm so
excited people it's an exciting time in
this story right I just wanted one of
these super exciting moments but here's
the funny thing about this right this is
not why Galactus gave him the ark he
immediately summons them telepathically
and he's like what's the meaning of this
and the responsive read is like you said
that we would know when to summon you
right like we would know the time this
is it Galactus and Galactus is like no
this is something different this is a
preamble I've consumed four worlds in
anticipation of something greater and so
when Reed's like well then what are you
talking like an entire Cree or like the
entire Cree Armada has left their home
Galaxy they've come here to Earth
they're launching an attack against us
we're all dying what could possibly be
worse than this right and the response
of Galactus is you read Richards I was
speaking of you I will handle the cree
Armada this dude shows up and it's just
like flat just like that right I mean
it's just annihilates most all of the
cree Armada now at that point the
Creed's like we gotta get out of here
man like the cree soldiers literally
tell the Supreme intelligence dude we
got like like this there's this Cree
soldiers talking to somebody like look
Supreme intelligence I know you've been
gone for 300 years there is a figure of
speech that we've developed in the time
that you've been gone and it goes like
this
get while the getting's good and we need
to get out of here man like we need to
like do Galactus is here they detonate
Mega bombs right like everything they
have their entire their entire like arms
like everything right like they fire
everything in this guy nothing happens
right because it's Galactus right like
bombs aren't gonna destroy this guy and
so the response to the Supreme
intelligence is is the anomaly close
right where's the inhuman vessel and
they're like it's right over there right
and it's making its way over to us but
then out of nowhere they're like
something's up here like what is this
like some things appeared here right and
it's not Galactus this thing like like
whatever these guys are blow away a huge
like what's left of the cree Armada it
gets completely and totally annihilated
and that's when Galactus turns around
and says this is why I'm here this is
the death I have foreshadowed mad gods
have come to destroy us the celestials
have arrived that's right ladies and
gentlemen the mad celestials at the
beginning of the story have made their
way into the main our universe how it is
they did that we will cover in the next
video but song song man let me tell you
something man it's about man it's about
to get cries about to get cloudy oh that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching I will catch you all later
peace